Salut.
Je commence cette vidéo par la fin.
On est le dimanche 7 janvier, il est 17H à
New York.
Je commence par la fin et je vais vous expliquer
pourquoi.
J'ai un problème avec ce micro.
Il m'a planté une partie de la vidéo en
faisant des bruits très bizarre.
Désolé d'introduire là dessus.
C'est juste pour que vous compreniez et que
vous m'excusiez car le premier plan que j'ai
fait ce matin je ne vais pas le refaire donc
forcément il y a du bruit dessus.
Je viens m'en excuser.
On va tout de suite parler de Casey.
New York.
Tout juste 7H du matin.
On va parler du roi des vlogueur aujourd'hui.
Je vais parler de celui qui m'a donné envie,
et comme beaucoup de mon d'ailleurs, de faire
des vidéos sur Youtube : Casey Neistat.
Son studio est à peine à 2 kilomètres d'ici.
On va voir énormément de choses sur lui
aujourd'hui.On va voir pleins de choses.
Mais avant toutes choses on va faire comme
lui un run matinal à 7H du matin.
Sauf que là il fait -15°C, il y a une énorme
vague de froid sur New York.
Mais bon, on s'en fout.
Quand on aime on ne compte pas.
C'est parti.
On y va.
Il fait froid.
C'est chaud de courir quand même, surtout
quand tu n'es pas sportif, à -15°C.
Comment il fait Casey ? C'est un malade.
C'est trop creuvant le sport.
Je vais manger un pancake, je vais faire du
gras, ça ça ira mieux.
Chapeau Casey, je ne sais pas comment tu fais.
C'est super bon.
Verdict: Bubby's c'est très très bon, hyper
dur à finir, je n'ai pas réussi.
Par contre c'est pas cadeau cadeau pour le
prix.
Si vous allez à New York je vous conseille
quand même de venir.
Vous trouverez Bubby's au croisement de Hudson
street et Moore.
C'est très très bon.
Vous allez vous régaler.
Maintenant on continue.
Là vous avez la
toute petite voiture de police dont laquelle
Casey Neistat se moquait sur une de ses dernières vidéos.
D'ailleurs il s'est pas mal fait reprendre
là dessus.
Allez jeter un coup d'oeil, c'est vrai que
c'est drôle.
Donc là on est à l'angle de Broadway et
de Franklin street et juste devant moi vous
avez les bureaux de Casey Neistat au premier
étage, juste à côté Beme.
Là au premier étage c'est les bureaux de
Casey Neistat avec la caméra qui sert à
filmer en permanence et là vous avez Beme,
la boite que Casey Neistat a fondé, a cofondé
et à revendu à CNN il y a quelques années.
L'année dernière, il y a un an, 2 ans, en
2016, pour 25 millions de dollars, c'est juste
complètement fou, qui fait du super contenu
de qualité, d'ailleurs je vous invite à
vous abonner car c'est vraiment un truc génial,
je vous ai mis le lien dans la description
si vous ne connaissez pas parce que c'est
vraiment une chaine à connaitre c'est génial.
Casey office.
Beme.
C'est un lieu de pèlerinage ici.
Ici c'est les bureaux de Casey Neistat.
No selfies mais il n'y est pas écrit si on
ne peut pas filmer alors je filme.
C'est là où sont ses bureaux.
Ca c'est l'endroit à Casey achète ses valises
pour partir.
Point de détail : on est juste à côté
de son bureau mais c'est quand même intéressant
à savoir.
Là on est au 35 Great Jones Street.
C'est l'endroit où se trouvent les bureaux
de Billy!.
Billy! c'est la marque de la femme de Casey Neistat
: Candice Pool Neistat.
C'est juste ici dans cette immeuble là, on
va aller jusqu'en haut.
Si vous suivez les vidéos de Casey Neistat,
vous verrez qu'il y a des choses qu'on reconnait
et notamment le parking derrière qu'on a
déjà vu plusieurs fois dans différentes vidéos.
Billy! c'est une marque qui fait des bijoux, il y
a les tshirts que portent énormément Casey Neistat.
Les tshirts Billy!.
Et il a déjà dit dans plusieurs vidéos
qu'il était très très fier de ce que faisait
Candice, qu'elle était elle aussi partie
de zéro, créer sa propre marque qui a l'air
de fonctionner.
Donc félicitations, c'est vraiment sympa.
C'est juste ici 35 Great Jones Street et désolé
pour mon accent.
Alors au final pourquoi est-ce que tout le
monde aime autant Casey ? Pourquoi est-ce
que c'est quelqu'un vraiment adoré ? Qui
a plus de 8 millions et demi d'abonnés et
ça continue de monter.
Pourquoi a t'il autant de succès ? Parce
que c'est un mec simple.
C'est un mec qui vient de nul part.
Il est parti très jeune de chez sa mère.
Il a eu son premier enfant il n'avait même
pas 20ans.
Il est venu à New York pour rejoindre son
frère et tenter sa chance et ça lui a plutôt
bien réussi.
Il a fait des vidéos qui ont buzzées.
Il a eu sa série avec son frangin sur HBO.
Ensuite sur Youtube, avec son vlog, il a cartonné.
Et maintenant il s'est imposé comme le roi
des vlogueurs, le numéro 1, celui qui a ouvert
une voie et qui a vraiment créé un style.
On le retrouve un peu partout.
C'est quelqu'un qui cartonne.
D'ailleurs ce petit produit, si vous allez
à New York, Juice Press.
J'ai pris le Juice Press anti âge avec du
concombre.
C'est vegan.
C'est pas mauvais.
J'ai l'impression de boire du concombre avec
de l'eau.
C'est pas mal mais bon pour 10 dollars ça
fait quand même un peu cher.
Et sinon ce petit produit que je vais essayer,
la sauce spicy Casey Neistat.
C'est pour ramener un souvenir.
Voila un peu ce que l'on peut dire aujourd'hui
sur Casey Neistat.
Merci d'avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Je vous invite à me laisser des pouces vers
le haut.
A vous abonner.
Et je vous dis à très bientôt.
Soyez sage.
Portez vous bien.
A bientôt.
Chao.